こんにちは、クリスと申します。
今日はDrupalDEN岩国でスペシャルトークをすることになり、光栄です。
今日は沖縄科学技術大学院大学の
リニューアルされたウェブサイトを発表します。
英語で技術的な内容を発表した方がやりやすいのですが、
それでも後で日本語でお話しして、ご意見をいただくのが楽しみです。
こんにちは、クリスと申します
本日、DrupalDEN岩国で特別講演を
させていただくことを光栄に思います。
本学OISTでは
Drupal 7のリリース初年度の2011年にサイトを構築しました。
サイトを構築しました。
Drupal 7はすべてのDrupalのバージョンの中で最も長い寿命を持ち、
プラットフォームに大きな変化をもたらしました。
これらの変更の1つは、
Content TypeのエンティティフィールドとしてCCKが統合され、
Viewsがコアにもたらされたことです。
さらに、ImageCacheはImage Styleに生まれ変わりました。
昨年、
私たちはDrupal 9を使用して
ウェブサイトを再構築するための2年間の旅を経験しました。
講演の前半では、
Webサイトの再構築の際に行った開発と
プロジェクト管理のプロセスについて説明します。
第二部では
英語と日本語のバイリンガルに向けたウェブサイトのローカライズで
直面した課題について、より深く掘り下げます。
また、単なる翻訳にとどまらず、どのような問題に直面したのか。
どのように対処し、ユーザーに最高のユーザーエクスペリエンスを
提供したかをお話しします。
まず、
僕のことを少しご紹介します。
私はDrupalの開発者で、14年の経験があります。
繁体字中国語、日本語、英語での
ウェブデザインと開発の経験が豊富です。
Drupalコミュニティのメンバーでもあり、
台湾の元グループリーダーでもあります。
Drupal以外では、
コーヒー、ドイツ、猫に興味があり、
これらのトピックについての会話も歓迎します。
本題に入る前に
この講演でベンダーやサービスについての言及があっても、
それを推奨するものではないことにご了承ください。
Drupal 7の旧サイトは、私たちによく貢献してくれました。
3,000万人以上の訪問者と37,000のコンテンツを提供しました。
この3年間で月間の訪問者数が2倍になりました。
このサイトでは、私たちの成果を世界に発信しています。
例えば、新しい研究棟が完成したとき。
Nature誌で高い影響力を持つランキングを獲得したとき。
ノーベル賞受賞などの成果を世界に発信しました。
私たちの成功を継続的に祝うサイトです。
しかし、私たちはこれからもイノベーションに努め、
日本の研究の未来を切り開いていきます。
これらの目標を達成するために
新しい目標を設定し、
より効果的で柔軟な方法で成果を
出せる新しいウェブサイトが必要でした。
2020年、沖縄科学技術大学院大学は戦略計画を定め
活動の3本柱を重視するようになりました：
研究、教育、そしてイノベーション。
また、STEM教育への関心を高め、
沖縄に貢献することも私たちの責務です。
そして、日本社会へのアウトリーチ活動も私たちの責務です。
プロジェクト全体を通して
この3つの柱を常に意識しています。
Webサイトが組織の戦略に合致するようにしました。
技術的な面では、
編集者のコンテンツ管理体験を向上させることが目標でした。
Drupal 9では、
メディアライブラリを使ってアセットを管理できるようになりました。
また、ノードの翻訳方法をフィールド翻訳に変更しました。
また、Drupalだけでなく、
ユーザーエクスペリエンスの一貫性を保つために
デザインシステムを導入し、
編集者がコンテンツを作成する際に
Webコンポーネントを簡単に再利用できるようにしています。
Webサイトプロジェクトは、大きく3つのフェーズに分かれていました。
2020年12月にベンダーと共同で包括的なユーザー調査を実施し、
ステークホルダーと社内外のユーザーへの理解を深めました。
この調査により、ユーザーが私たちをどのように
認識しているのかが明らかになりました。
と、ウェブサイトの情報アーキテクチャを
どのように改善すればよいかを明らかにしました。
第2フェーズでは Drupal 9を使用した新しいWebサイトの構築と
コンテンツの移行を別のベンダーに依頼しました。
ベンダーが開発を完了した後、
当社のウェブチームがコンテンツを引き継ぎました。
私たちはそれを変換してコンテンツを作り直し、
コンテンツ所有者に新しいウェブサイトの
使い方をトレーニングしています。
また、開発者と私は、更新作業と追加問題の解決に取り組みます。
プロジェクト開始から2年後の昨年12月、
無事リニューアルを果たしました。
OISTのコミュニティからも好評をいただいています。
それでは、早速サイトを覗いてみましょう。
カラースキームを再定義し、
サイト全体に新しいウェブコンポーネントを使用しました。
メガメニューは、ユーザーにより良いナビゲーションマップを提供します。
メディア・エディターは、
関連コンテンツを手動で選択することも、
システムに関連コンテンツを選択させることも可能です。
フリッカーをサイトに統合し
ユーザーが写真集をプレビューできるようにしました。
さまざまなキャンペーンや特別委員会のために、
マイクロサイト機能を設け、
独自のコンテンツを管理し、独自のロゴを表示できるようにしました。
最後に、私たちがウェブサイトのために
デザインしたコンポーネントを紹介するスタイルガイドも作成しました。
さて、次は技術的な面です。
ここでは、マイグレーションプロセスの概要と、
開発プロジェクトの管理方法について説明したいと思います。
マイグレーションは、
私たちのプロジェクトにおいて最初にして最も重要な要素でした。
重要なコンテンツや資産はすべて移行する必要があります。
コンテンツノードの移行だけでなく、
CMSで管理されていないファイルや画像も移行する必要がありました。
Drupal 7 では。Media Libraryがありませんでした。
そのため、アセットを格納するために
「video」と「photo」コンテンツタイプを使用しました。
そして、コンテンツ本文の中でショートコードを使ってそれらを参照していました。
つまり、まず3,000のコンテンツノードと
6,000以上のメディアアセットをすべて移行する必要がありました。
そして、インラインのショートコードをすべて
新しいメディア埋め込み形式に変換する必要がありました。
これまでコンテンツエディターは、
IMCEを利用してファイルや画像を
直接サーバーにアップロードすることができました。
今回の移行では、
1,500以上のインラインファイルソースをメディアタイプに変換しました。
これには画像、ドキュメント、埋め込み動画が含まれます。
これにより、すべてのファイルが管理されたシステム内にあることが保証されるだけでなく、
システムの安全性も向上しました。
Drupal Migrate APIスクリプトを利用して、
合計で10,000以上のコンテンツやアセットを移行しています。
移行プロファイルは、
テスト目的のモックアップデータを提供するために、
プロジェクトで使い続けました。
各新機能の開発中ローカル環境とクラウドCI環境では、
毎回モックアップデータを使用してサイトを構築しています。
これにより、ユニットテストを繰り返し実行し、
より堅牢で信頼性の高いデプロイメントを実現することができました。
移行はプロジェクトにとって重要であり、
内容の確認や結果の検証に多くの労力を要しました。
しかし、その価値はあり、
プロジェクトの成功に重要な役割を果たしました。
移行にとどまらず、
プロジェクトを成功に導いた3つの鍵があります。
私たちは、チームと上司に進捗状況を常に伝えるようにしました。
OISTは大きな組織であり、多くの意思決定ルートがあります。
そのため、必要に応じてステークホルダーと直接面談を行いました。
また、適切なルートでサポートし、
コミュニケーションを取れる人を探しました。
プロジェクトのタスクを管理し、
コミュニケーションを支援するツールを効果的に使っています。
ベストなツールはありませんが、
チームメンバー全員が喜んで使える適切なツールを探しました。
繰り返しの作業とリスクを減らすために、
私たちはテストとプロセスの自動化に可能な限り頼っています。
これら全ての要素が相まって、プロジェクトは成功するのです。
プロジェクトの最初の段階で、ベンダーは
GitHubとそのProjectツールを使ってタスク管理を行いました。
これにより、開発者と私たちは、
プロジェクトマネージャーを通したコミュニケーションだけでなく、
自由にコミュニケーションをとることができるようになりました。
これにより、開発のスピードアップ、作業の透明化、
相互の信頼関係の向上が図られました。
納品後は、Shortcutを導入し、
開発とコンテンツ制作の両タスクを
同じプラットフォームで管理するようにしました。
Shortcutでは、GitHubを統合してプルリクエストの状況を把握し、
開発タスクの状況を同期させることができました。
GitHubはすでに多くの人が知っており、
そのプロジェクト管理ツールはより成熟し、使いやすくなっています。
Shortcutは開発作業と編集作業の両方を
簡単に管理できるタスク管理システムです。
開発と編集のタスクは
それぞれ異なるワークフローを必要とすることから、
Shortcutでそれぞれ異なるワークフローを作成し、
それらを同じEpicやIterationに簡単に取り込むことができます。
これは、複数の機能を持つチームにとって非常に便利な機能です。
Shortcutで Githubと開発タスクのステータスを
素早く同期させることができますね。
別々のプラットフォームでありながら、
両者の間でシームレスに仕事ができるのです。
2人の開発者で構成される開発チームであり、
開発タスクと問題解決に集中する必要があります。
CI/CDプロセスは第3の開発者の役割を果たし、
コーディング標準をチェックし、
私たちに代わってコードをデプロイしてくれます。
これにより、開発者はコードをオンライン開発環境にコミットした後、
次のタスクに素早く移ることができます。
コミットがCI/CDワークフローを通過したら、
あとはプルリクエストでコードのロジックのレビューに専念し、
CI/CDに本番環境へのデプロイを依頼することができるのです。
ツール、スクリプト、そして継続的なコミュニケーションにより、
プロジェクトをスムーズに完了させることができました。
もちろん、勤勉なチームメンバーの存在が、
プロジェクト成功の核となった。
OISTは、職員や学生を含め、メンバーの50％以上が
外国人であるという、日本ではユニークな大学院大学です。
私たちの細胞シグナルユニットもその例にもれず、
第一線の教授陣、研究仲間、
そして学生も世界各国から集まっています。
そのため、
OISTでは英語と日本語が同じくらい重要視されており、
ホームページのコンテンツもほとんどが両言語に翻訳されています。
プロジェクト期間中、私たちは多くの翻訳問題に取り組みました。
本講演の第二部では、
特に日本やAPAC地域の参加者のために、
そのうちのいくつかに焦点を当てたいと思います。
Drupalはコアにしっかりとした翻訳システムを持っています。
あなたの経験や役割に応じて、
翻訳を行う方法は常にあります。
サイト構築者として、
フィールド翻訳を有効にしたノードを翻訳することができます。
また、ユーザーインターフェースに
表示される多くの文字列を翻訳することができます。
TWIGを使って、変数が入った翻訳可能な文章をマークしています。
デベロッパーとして
開発者としては、t() 関数で
翻訳可能な文字列をマークすればいいのです。
文中で動的変数を使用することも可能です。
しかし、単語が動詞であったり名詞であったり、
複数の意味を持つため、翻訳文脈が必要な場合がある。
例えば
"コンタクト"
日本語では2種類の言葉に翻訳されます
アクションとして、「コンタクト」。
セクションラベルとしては、"連絡先 "です。
ユーザーエクスペリエンスのローカライズについては、
最新のDrupalCon Pragueでの私の講演に詳細があります。
もし、あなたが興味を持っていて、
バイリンガルサイトによく携わっているのであれば、
参考になるかと思います。
しかし、今日はプロジェクト特有の、
日本語に関連する問題に焦点を当てたいと思います。
考慮すべき問題のひとつは、日付の形式です
日本や台湾では、
年、月、日の順に記載する形式が一般的です。
海外では、国によって
9月12日とも12月9日とも解釈される日付形式をよく見かけます。
例えば、ヨーロッパの多くの国では12月9日と読みますが、
アメリカでは9月12日と読みます。
OISTのメンバーの多様性を考えると、
情報の理解を一致させるために
共通の方法を見つけなければなりません。
そのため、英語版UIではISO 8601形式を使用します。というのは、
日本語のUIでも同じ順序でフォーマットされているからです
また、日本語、中国語、韓国語の入力も重要な課題です。
CJK言語と呼ばれることもあります。
キーボードでローマ字を打つのは比較的簡単ですが、
CJK言語ではどのように文字を打つのでしょうか。
ここでは、"保健所からCOVID-19陽性の通知を受けたらどうするか "について、
日中韓の言語でいくつかの段落を紹介します。
CJK言語では、
文に空白が入ることはほとんどありません。
内容をインデックス化し、検索しやすくするために、
通常は余分な処理が必要である。
では、日中韓のキーボードはどうなっているのだろうか。
左から右へ
繁体字中国語のキーボードが2つあります。
そして、携帯電話には韓国語キーボードと
日本語キーボードの2つのレイアウト、
つまり50音順のコンパクトなキーボードレイアウトがあります。
知らない人にとっては、
パズルのように見えるかもしれません。
単語を入力する際、キーストロークが異なる。
「コンピュータ」という単語も、
台湾の繁体字中国語と中国の簡体字中国語では異なることがわかる。
日中韓の言語を入力する場合、
すべてのセグメントを入力して初めて1つの単語が完成する。
英語と違って、
入力が完了する前に単語の組み合わせがあるかもしれない。
動画の中では、
日本語の漢字を入力するには
、1～4個、あるいはそれ以上の
発音要素を入力する必要があることが示されています。
さらに、
漢字には同じ読みを持つ異なる単語が存在します。
このため、検索ボックスでは、
実際にキーワードを入力し終わる前に検索が始まってしまい、
ユーザーに迷惑をかけるという問題があります。
この問題は、JavaScriptの特別なイベントメソッドを実装し、
キーワード入力の完了を待ってから
検索をトリガーすることで改善されます。
この動画では、
いくつかの改善が見られました。
英語の入力は正常に行われ、
日本語の「コロナ」は、
単語が完成した時点で初めて検索されることがわかります。
Drupalでは、タグや参照する実体のオートコンプリート欄があります。
コアには以前からこの問題がありましたが、2016年、
Drupalのコントリビューターのおかげで修正されました。
主に、入力が終わった時の特別なイベントを特定するために、
CompositionEventを使用しています。
このカスタムオートコンプリート検索ボックスを作成したとき、
イベントも実装する必要がありました。
まず、CJK入力メソッドの開始位置を検出します。
次に、compositionEndイベントが起こるので、
単語が決定するまで待ちます。
最後に、このAJAXリクエストを送信します。
タイピングの問題に続いて、ソートの問題を見てみましょう。
英語では、記事のタイトル、
分類タグ、名前など、アルファベットを使ってソートすることが多い。
しかし、日本語や中国語でソートする場合は、まったく違います。
日本語では、五十音の順番で並べ替えることは、
ほとんどの人が知っています。
そして、漢字もあります。
ある配列の中に、
アルファベット、数字、ひらがな、カタカナ、
漢字がある場合、
どのようにすれば正しく並べられるのでしょうか。
日本語の理想的な順番は、右のようなものです。
英語のように簡単な数字のアルファベットから始まり、
ひらがな、カタカナ、そして最後に漢字。
ひらがな、カタカナは五十音の順番で並んでいます。
漢字ではどのような順番になるのでしょうか？
sort() 関数を直接使うと、
Unicodeテーブルの各文字の
インデックス番号に基づいて配列がソートされます。
しかし、これは日本語話者にとっては意味がありません。
なぜなら、文字の並び順は
その言語での適切な並び方を反映していないからです。
JavaScriptの関数localeCompare()を使えば、
最初の文字の読み方に基づいて漢字をソートすることができます。
最初の文字が同じなら次の文字も同じにする
PHPにも似たような関数がありますが、
バックエンドでよりよいソート結果を得るには、
データベースクエリを使用することが推奨されます。
しかし、これは完璧ではなく、真ん中の単語が1つだけ間違っています。
岩下
漢字に別の発音があるからです。
最初の文字は「いわ」ではなく、
「がん」と読みます。
もうひとつ、同じ漢字で「かわの」、「こうの」という名字もあります。
日本語でも中国語でも、
この漢字は複数の発音を持つことができるんですね。
複数の発音を持つ文字はいくつあるのでしょうか？
日本には2,000ある文字のうち、
600以上の文字が複数の読み方を持っています。
台湾の教育部による公式定義では
一般的に使用される繁体字中国語は5,000字中1,263字であった。
10年ほど前に、
その多くを見直し、統合して
580字に減らした。
漢字を例にしてみましょう。
文化的背景が異なるため、より多くの発音がある。
そのうちの4つは、
様々な時代の古代中国から受け継いだ音読であり、
もう4つは本来の日本語の訓読を表している。
元の中国語漢字はよく似ていて、
3つの発音がある。
この文字は、「音楽」を表す樂（ユエ）、
「幸せ・幸福」を表す樂（ル）、
「鑑賞する」という動詞を表す樂（ヤオ）の頭文字をとったものである。
これで
日本語の発音順がわかりましたね。繁体字中国語はどうでしょうか。
それでは、台湾の美味しいものを紹介しましょう。
私の好きな順に
並べてみました。
では、属性を使って名前を並べ替えるにはどうしたらいいのでしょう？
まず、どのような方法があるか見てみましょう。
これは岩国の一文字
繁体字中国語で "イェン"。
少なくとも4種類の並べ方があります。
部首の画数を数える方法、
総画数を数える方法、
台湾でのみ使われている
音素注音で表記する方法、
または中国での主な入力方法であるローマ字による
ピンインで表記する方法である。
通常はいずれかの属性で並び替えを行うが、
図書館の蔵書検索システムのように、
ユーザーが並び替えの方法を変更できるようにすることもある。
繁体字中国語では、
localeCompare() は先に述べた様々な属性とも連動します。
画数で、
または音声注音で。
これは音韻の要素である注音でソートしています。
五十音で日本語をソートするのと同じようなものです。
注音を理解しないと、理解するのは難しいでしょう。
でも、別の方法はもっと簡単です。
これは総画数でソートしています。
左から右へ、最初の文字の
ストロークが多くなっているのがわかります。
JavaScriptがサポートされてるのがすごいよね。
これはオープンソースの貢献者のおかげです。
特にUniHanプロジェクトは、
ユニコードのオープンソースプロジェクトの一つです。
そのおかげで、これが使えるようになったんです。
そこで、未解決の問題を考えてみよう。
多読漢字をどうするか？
この問題は、日本語の漢字、
あるいは漢字を発音要素の注音やピンインで
並べ替えたときに発生する。
技術的には、ネイティブスピーカーは、
一般的な発音のバリエーションを知っており、
頭の中で処理する際、一緒に処理されるため、
異なる発音が混在していても、ネイティブスピーカーは
あまり気にならないのである。
ただし、私の認識が間違っている可能性もありますので、
具体的な解決策をお聞かせいただければと思います。
もし、クライアントが明示的な順序を要求してきた場合は、
あらかじめ定義されたテーブルや配列に単語を
マッピングするのが良い方法です。
最後に、ある一文を紹介したい。
"Devil is in the details"
という言葉を耳にすることがある。
この意味は、「細部にまで目を向けないと、
困難や問題は見えてこない」というものである。
文の成り立ちが何となく逆なんですよね。
"神は細部に宿る"
ドイツの建築家、
ミース・ファン・デル・ローエの言葉です。
"Der liebe Gott steckt im detail" である。
悪魔でも神でも、
この文に共通することは一つ。
一番大事なことは、細かいところにある。
新しいサイトが完成したとき、人々は歓声を上げ、満足感を覚えます。
そして、そのウェブサイトを訪れた人が、
自分の言語で直感的に操作できることに喜びを感じるとき。
それは、開発者・デザイナーが最高のUXを実現するために、
細部にまでこだわっているからです。
そして、よく見て、チャレンジして、
悪魔と取引して、
最後には輝かしい奇跡を見つけましょう。
どうも、クリスです。今日は以下のセッションで良い午後を過ごせますように。
ご清聴ありがとうございました。